Aaron Kina Colson Vanguard was a first
wave Strategic Homeland division agent
who would go on to disavow the division
and go Rogue
his intelligence and all-round Cockiness
has by far made him one of the most
popular antagonists in the franchise so
in his partner's story suddenly ended we
were left asking a ton of questions
fortunately with year 5 having now been
announced we can see that season 3 will
be revealing more details around Aaron
Kina and his Rogues so for now this
video will be a recap of everything you
know about him so far
[Music]
Aaron Kina is a complex and ambiguous
individual whose personality encompasses
a range of traits and characteristics he
is known for his intelligence
adaptability and strategic thinking
which have played significant roles in
shaping his actions and decisions
Kina possesses a high level of
intelligence allowing him to analyze
situations and devise intricate plans
his intellectual prowess enables him to
understand complex systems and exploit
their weaknesses to his Advantage he is
a quick thinker capable of making
calculated decisions even under immense
pressure
adaptability is another key aspect of
kina's Personality he has shown the
ability to adjust and thrive in various
environments whether it be his military
service Wall Street career or his role
within the Strategic Homeland division
this adaptability allows him to navigate
different social dynamics and
effectively manipulate those around him
to further his own goals
volcano's intellect and versatility
contribute to a success they also
highlight his manipulative nature
he possesses a talent for persuasion
ethically convincing others to join his
cause or carry out his bidding his
personal demeanor allows him to build
rapport with individuals creating a
sense of trust and loyalty that he can
exploit to further his own agenda
underneath his Charming facade there is
a darker side to kina's personality he
is driven by a strong sense of
self-interest and is willing to do
whatever it takes to achieve his goals
even if that means resorting to rootless
tactics or sacrificing the lives of
others this ruthless nature combined
with his Brilliance and flexibility
makes him a formidable adversary
despite his flaws and morally
questionable actions Kina possesses a
charismatic aura that draws people
towards them is the capability to
inspire loyalty and convince others to
follow his lead even if that means
deviating from their own plans and
morals this charismatic manipulation
contributes to his strengths in
assembling a loyal group of followers
and directing them to serve his own
agenda
it's also worth noting that keena's
version of help often comes at a
significant cost his methods can involve
violence manipulation and the sacrifice
of innocent lives
he operates in a morally gray area where
the ends justify the means in his mind
while some may argue that his actions
have unintended consequences and may
cause more harm than good heena
genuinely believes that he is working
towards a better future additionally
Keener is used his intelligence and
knowledge to expose the corruption and
hidden agendas of powerful organizations
such as the Strategic Homeland Division
and the Black Tusk in his Twisted logic
he believes that by revealing the true
nature of these groups and forcing them
to confront their own flaws he is
ultimately helping Humanity by removing
the veil of false security
he possesses a unique perspective on the
world and believes that by dismantling
the existing systems he can bring about
a new order that he considers more just
and humane
although seen as one of the biggest
threats to the division and all Humanity
there have been instances where he has
shown his willingness to help others
albeit in his own Twisted way one such
example is the events with a firefighter
and his family which stands as a
compelling reminder of the intricate
layers that compose arenkina's
personality
[Music]
yeah thanks to you anybody else alive in
there no
these guys were offering us a place to
stay until my chief could pull some
strings and get us back to Brooklyn oh
well that's not gonna happen you can't
stay here
oh you better come with us we'll get you
somewhere safe we will yes we will we
sure appreciate it try to keep up
hey man what are you doing I write this
second with these trays you got a thing
for firemen they seem like decent people
in a bad situation there's a lot of
decent people in bad situations on this
[__] Island we're gonna give them an
armed escort too maybe if I decide they
deserve one I don't get a say in this no
you don't
don't look Gracie keep your eyes closed
these guys are jtf they were what
happened here they got shot by who
I don't see any other bodies doesn't
matter grab anything useful we need to
muff
I think they killed those jtf guys how
do you know some of them were shot at
the back
a few of them weren't even carrying
weapons why would they shoot ktf I don't
know I'm not sure I Wanna Know I mean if
they wanted to kill us what's stopping
them you guys really suck at whispering
get some rest
tomorrow is a big day
I told you I'd get you to safety
I'm a man of my word
now wait about an hour and then row as
hard as you can for the other Shore you
want us to wait on this part of the
Hudson flows both ways right now it's
slack tied the end current will make
crossing a lot easier and faster what if
we're spotted oh with this wind you
should have plenty of time to get a
cross between patrols thanks for keeping
your word I remember what I said
this situation is only gonna get worse
avoid crowds and assume everybody you
meet is a threat
now you might have a chance I hope your
technical difficulties get sorted out
we'll manage
you about ready in a minute how long are
you gonna sit there they made it they're
safe can we go now us a rush you got
somewhere you need to be you still
haven't told me why we helped them I'm
guilty conscience
is that what you want to hear
trying to offset my misdeeds with a
random act of kindness helping strangers
doesn't really follow the recruiting
pitch just want to know if you're going
to make this a regular thing
all right let's read the interrogation
you put us at risk I want to know why
truth
he went into the building he what when
we first saw him in the West Village the
smart thing would have been to get the
hell out of there that's what most
people would have done but he didn't do
the smart thing he did the right thing
that's [__] the smart thing is the
right thing maybe
probably
but it made me want him to survive so it
was a fireman thing come on let's get
out of here we have work to do
recognizing the perilous situation and
driven by a sense of Duty Tina decided
to step in and offer his assistance
despite the darkness that looked within
him his chicken passed and being a rogue
agent he understood the importance of
protecting the vulnerable in times of
crisis
ultimately Aaron keena's actions
underscored the multi-dimensionality of
his Persona blurring the lines between
hero and villain
and his deeds both good and bad
contributed to the intricate Narrative
of this situation and the many events
within the game's story
however it's important to note that
keener's Noble acts are more of an
exception rather than the norm in his
overall trajectory as often any
subsequent actions and choices are
eventually overshadowed as he reverts
back towards more Sinister nature he
will always continue to pursue his own
controversial agenda and wage his own
personal war against the existing order
Aaron Keane is privileged upbringing
provided him with a head start in life
and access to resources that many others
did not have
coming from a wealthy family he enjoyed
certain advantages and opportunities
that shaped his early years
growing up in an environment of comfort
and effluence Keena had access to
Quality education extracurricular
activities and a supportive Network
he received the best schooling available
allowing him to develop his intellect
and expand his Horizons this privileged
background helped Foster a sense of
confidence and entitlement within him
he was an ambitious and driven
individual always seeking new challenges
and opportunities to prove himself
he possessed sharp intellect and a
natural aptitude for strategic thinking
which set him apart from his peers
Aaron Keener eventually enrolled in the
Citadel the esteemed Military College of
South Carolina
this decision marked a pivotal moment in
his life as it set the foundation for
his future accomplishments in the
military and Beyond
The Citadel renowned for its rigorous
academic and military training programs
provided Kino with a comprehensive
education that fostered discipline
leadership and a strong sense of Duty
immersed in a structured environment he
honed his physical and mental abilities
developing the necessary skills to excel
in challenging situations
during his time at the Citadel Kina
underwent extensive military training
preparing him for the demanding
responsibilities that lay ahead
fitness exercises to Tactical
simulations he acquired the knowledge
and practical experience needed to
navigate the complexities of military
life the college also instilled in Kina
a deep appreciation for values such as
Integrity honor and service these
principles would shape his character and
influence his actions throughout his
career by immersing himself in the
citadel's rigorous academic curriculum
and embracing his military training Kina
was equipped with a strong Foundation
that would prove invaluable in his
future endeavors
after completing his education he sought
a path that would allow him to make a
meaningful impact and fulfill his sense
of Duty he found his calling in the
military where he enlisted with a strong
determination to serve his country and
protect its citizens
he served a tour of Duty at Camp
Luminaire and Djibouti
Kina proved to be a dedicated and
disciplined Soldier he demonstrated
exceptional leadership skills earning
the respect of his comrades and
superiors
after leaving the military Aaron Kina
transitioned into a completely different
world Wall Street
utilizing his sharp decision-making
skills and the discipline he acquired
during his military service Keener
embarked on a career as a future Trader
working on Wall Street Kina found
himself in the midst of the fast paced
and Cutthroat environment of High
Finance
with his intellect and adaptability he
quickly made a name for himself
demonstrating an innate ability to
navigate the complexities of the
financial markets keena's military
background likely played a significant
role in his success on Wall Street the
discipline strategic thinking and risk
management skills he honed during his
time in the military transitioned well
into the world of Finance his capacity
to assess and seize opportunities
combined with a calculated approach to
risk allowed him to thrive in this
competitive industry
as a Futures Trader Kina would have been
involved in analyzing market trends
making predictions and executing trades
based on his insights his ability to
stay calm under pressure and make quick
informed decisions would have been
essential in this fast-paced environment
it's worth noting that Keenan's
transition to Wall Street showcases his
versatility and adaptability moving from
a military career to the finance
industry demonstrates his capacity to
thrive in different contexts and
leverage his skills and knowledge in new
and challenging ways
Aaron keener's personal life has seen
him married twice while specific details
around his marriages are limited it is
known that both unions eventually ended
in divorce
despite the disillusion of his marriages
Kina maintained amicable relationships
with his ex-bouses
according to one of his Ex-Wives he
could be demanding and challenging to
keep up with suggesting that he sets
high expectations for himself and those
around him the supplies that Keener is
not one to settle for mediocracy and
constantly seeks for self-improvement
and excellence in all aspects of his
life
keena's personal nature allows him to
build rapport and Foster relationships
with individuals from diverse
backgrounds
here's a neck for understanding people's
motivations and desires which enables
him to effectively communicate and
collaborate with them
it wasn't long before Kina was noticed
by the Strategic Homeland division's
recruitment team his experience and
Military expertise positioned him as the
ideal candidate for the shd
when Keno was approached with the
opportunity to join the ranks he eagerly
embraced it
the chance to put his abilities to the
test in a realm only known to a select
few intrigued him
he recognized the gravity of the
situation and understood that the tasks
ahead would require only the very best
as a part of the first wave of division
agents Aaron Keener was among the
individuals chosen to be activated in
response to the outbreak of the green
poison
with the city ravaged by the deadly
virus kina's mission was clear to
restore order and provide security in
the face of Chaos
one of his primary objectives assigned
by the division was to secure and
establish control over what would later
become known as the dark Zone
this designated area originally
conceived as a containment zone for
infected citizens presented unique
challenges and dangers
it was a lawless and volatile territory
with desperation and survival instincts
ran high among both the infected and the
remaining survivors
amidst the chaos and escalating violence
that engulfed the streets of Manhattan
Aaron Keener and his fellow division
agents followed their mission protocols
tasks with preserving order and
upholding the quarantine measures they
stood as the last line of defense
against spreading Devastation caused by
the green poison outbreak
however
Sarah and the jtf had other plans
they would go on to cut their losses and
ordered all forces to pull out of the
dark Zone at all costs
Aaron Keener the first wave agents and
thousands of infected had been abandoned
lift to fend for themselves
Kina felt betrayed
during the jtf's retreat Aaron was
leading a group of civilians out of the
dark Zone when they were ambushed by a
group of Rikers
Kina sheltered the civilians in a
department building and continued to
fend off the overwhelming number of
hostiles
realizing the dioness of the situation
Kina desperately reached out to the jtf
for much needed reinforcements
he relayed the gravity of the Ambush and
the imminent danger faced by the
civilians and himself
however to his dismay his pleas fell on
death ears
the jtf caught up in their own Retreat
denied his request for assistance
leaving him and the civilians to fend
for themselves
[Music]
are you listening to me I brought these
people out of the dark Zone and we were
followed I tried to hold up in a jtf
saved us with the Rikers out there doing
back off if you don't pull us out these
people are all dead
Angel sticks out
so that's it we just wait to die but if
I can help it
[Applause]
after a malt of cocktail was thrown into
the building everyone was killed apart
from Kina who managed to escape
this incident changed Keenan's
perspective of the federal government
and it left him disenchanted with his
role as a division agent feeling a great
deal of anger and betrayal
it was at this moment that he decided to
withdraw from his missions and disavow
the Strategic Homeland division
breakdown
Predators protectors they start looking
an awful lot alike
hard to tell them apart don't you think
as a division agent heena felt a sense
of duty to protect the weak and innocent
but after being denied help and the
civilians under his care were killed by
the Rikers he felt a great deal of anger
and betrayal from the government as he
believed he could have saved the
civilians and that the first wave could
have saved the dark Zone altogether at
the government being more competent
after going rogue his determination and
perseverance stayed the same only his
goals and loyalties have changed heena
strongly believes that the man-made
contagion that had been introduced had
created a new reality one that infected
not just the dark zone or the city of
New York or even the United States but
the entire history of the human species
he now believes that rule and law no
longer exists and that the only way to
survive is by obtaining power
his first action after turning Rogue was
to get the first wave agents and form a
unit that would work with them to
achieve his goals
agents who chose not to Ally with them
were killed in Cold Blood
so I gave you a chance to work with me
and you decided you were going to turn
me in instead for God's sake you don't
have to do this you need help you've
gone crazy
hey you're back talking to the guy with
the gun I'd say you're the crazy one me
I'm feeling real sane about things
hang on I'm just finishing up here
I'll be right over
if division agents could band together
as highly trained individuals with
unmatched technical skills instead of
the art gear that form an Unstoppable
force a force that would be perfectly
suited to seize control of the new world
that was being created in front of them
and this was the event that triggered
the activation of the second wave of
division agents
Aaron Keener would eventually meet with
Charles Bliss the commanding officer of
the last man battalion
as the strongest faction in Manhattan
Kina wanted to make use of the lmb to
help establish dominance and Bliss was
willing to work with Kina in order to
further gain advantage of the other
factions using his shd technology
together Keener and Bliss launched many
operations against the other factions
including the jtf in the division
one of the most notable being a missile
attack on a jtf helicopter that was
carrying the division's second wave
Commander as well as the majority of the
second wave division agents
during this time Keena was also running
his own investigation into the dollar
flew outbreak
it was around this time that the second
wave discovered several bodies of the
first wave division agents in several
Clues and even CCTV footage that pointed
to Aaron Keener and his involvement
towards the Mia agents
later on the second wave of his task was
saving scientists Dr Vitale trinenko
from the Russian consulate but when
attempting to access the Panic Room
Rogue agents working with Kino break in
kidnapping tranenko and escaping by a
helicopter
it has discovered that Kina has
hadroninko taken to the lmb headquarters
at the United Nations building
the division and jtf storm the U.N
building and put an end to the l b
control over New York
with the secondary objective of funny
troninko and Kina
however Kina was prepared for this he
realizes that the lmv have finished and
will be quickly dealt with by the
division
so he evacuates with trinica instructing
two of his Rogue agents to stay behind
and jam the shd tracking Hardware
allowing him to clean getaway
the lmb are driven out of the U.N
building and Charles Bliss aware of
keena's betrayal is defeated while
defeating his men in a last stand
against the government forces
following the L B defeat the division
learns that Kina has found amherst's lab
the creator of the original smallpox
virus that has crippled society as we
know it
Kina took the virus bubbles a 3D DNA
printer and as many of amherst's
research notes that he could fit into a
bag before once again disappearing
oh here I am Aaron Keener the first
waves Prodigal Son
normally I do this face to face but I'm
not 100 sure which way you'll jump you
act one way when Ms Lao is watching and
another way entirely when you're off the
leash that's an interesting
contradiction
here's the idea of it deep down you get
it you know the old rules laws
governments those things died on Black
Friday but the feral pmcs the convicts
the ones smart enough and good enough to
take what they need they'll survive me
I'm gonna prosper
oh you could too but you took an oath
right you got a duty
those are both ways of saying that your
conscience is [__] you
you ask yourself who's earned a right to
tell you what to do
you know how many agents died the whole
the dark Zone just for the brass to give
up and put a wall around it
you don't believe me
you should check the place out for
yourself
but the people you're working for
they're irrelevant now
Amherst changed how the game is played
and I have got the vision to win
I got chernenko I got a DNA printer and
a very interesting recipe book
I'm going to write my own rules
you should think about getting in on
this thing
I'll be seeing you
[Music]
at this point in time the division is
well aware of Aaron keener's activities
he is now haunted for high treason and
there is the possibility that Uber now
registered as a terrorist
with the recent deployment of both the
division and the jtf the West Side Pier
to help secure the area numerous
smartphone messages have been found in
the field with some of them being left
behind by Kina himself heena states that
he decided to broadcast his location to
the wizard piers in order to bring all
hostile factions to the area at this
stage they all seem to have some sort of
Feud with him especially the lmb
this was to ensure that the division
would be brought along in order to keep
their eyes off the prize
these messages revealed that Kino was
indeed in the west side Pier hunting
down a few things that he needed for his
plans given the fact that by now
according to him both Central and
Eastern Manhattan had been picked clean
of anything useful to him
his views and feelings towards the
government at this stage have only grown
in intensity
expresses his concerns and confusion on
why the jtf and the division are wasting
their time on helping people who aren't
worth it and that they should just be
left behind
his last message states that he is now
well and truly gone and also reveals
that he's got his eyes set on not just
the United States but now the world
the final thing that Keena States is
that should any second wave division
agent who is able to understand and
willing to join his mission not bother
looking for him he would find them when
the time was right
six months later multiple audio logs
left behind by Aaron Keener were
recovered in Washington DC the majority
of these were left behind to further
taunt the division but one of the audio
logs talks about the quarantine in
Manhattan and how it is falling apart
he also indicates that he has since
returned to New York with the Telly
around Coney Island in Brooklyn
many months later they both seem to have
come out of hiding
I don't know why he's forcing me to make
this
I don't know if I want to know killer
never does anything by chance that is
always a purpose at least one
sometimes ten through everything he does
I don't want to speculate because it's
the dark
knowing the things he's done and the
things this new virus can do but if
we're lucky he will use this on himself
and this is all just an elaborate way to
get me to kill him in a very dramatic
fashion I don't know how anyone could
live with themselves after the things he
has done
I don't know how to live with myself I
didn't know what I was doing when I was
working with Amherst that work was about
science not the application I didn't see
the applications but now with Kinder's
virus I see too many and all of them
terrify me
I'm sorry Mr Kenneth I don't know what
happened it's okay
we can try again I don't have any more
of the viral samples
they were destroyed in the experiment
that's fine you don't keep all your eggs
in one basket I get more you have more
of the virus of course Vitale I can get
you whatever you need
just stay focused on your work and try
to stay calm
you make silly mistakes when you're
stressed
I wouldn't want you to hurt yourself
thank you Mr Kina sleep well
I'll get you another sample I will see
you in the morning good night Mr Kenai
Kino is using vitelli to create and
perfect as new and improved version of
the virus
vitelli was trying his best not to help
and in fact sabotage the project but
Kina being Keener was prepared for this
the latest version is more potent and
the time from exposure determination has
been cut in half average time of death
after exposure on the last batch was 5
minutes and 24 seconds
results are promising
Kina will be pleased
this is not me
this is not who I wanted to be
I wanted to help people
to cure cancer with viruses not to
weaponize them but you know
forces me to use my research too I wish
I was brave enough to take my own life
but
I can't
I'm a coward
it would be so easy to just drop a vial
on the ground and let it take me
but I can't
if I get it down to one minute then
I think I wouldn't be afraid anymore
I could handle that pain for a minute
but not for five
okay
back to work
the Telly was well looked after Burkina
but he is still pushing him to do
something that was completely against
his morals
Kinder is a dangerous man and vitelli is
aware of what he's capable of
although he's been good to him as far as
one could be when being held captive
vitelli is worried about what might
happen to him if he doesn't do what is
instructed
he is alone and he's been hostage for so
long that has no idea if anyone is even
looking for him or even knows he's
missing
in vitelli's eyes feel strong enough he
would have removed himself from the
equation long ago
the sort of work wasn't him he wanted to
help people but he is an academic not a
hero
are you finished yes
to talk about your next project please
there is also the latest experiments are
violent enough
please don't make me create something
like that again oh no Vitale
misunderstand me are you going to kill
me
Vitali of course not
I'm letting you go you are I found a
group that will keep you safe are you
really done exceptional work and people
are starting to take notice who are
these people Black Tusk now you like
them they're a very elite group and
professional they'll keep you
busy
eventually videlli completed kina's task
it created a new weaponized version of
the virus it was capable of killing
someone who was exposed in just over
five minutes
so Keenan now has a new plan for him
he was gifting him to the Black Tusk but
what was it getting for him in return
is well aware of the value of having
such an asset so the Black Tusk must
have something that he really wants
so what's the deal here you just going
to give us chinenko yes and what do you
want in return I got
don't worry it's a reasonable trade
I'll send you the details from what I've
heard about you you don't strike me as
reasonable you can't believe everything
you hear
gloris Jones
we're not on a first name basis you're
not my friend Kina you're a tough cookie
Jones
I don't respect that
Kina contacted the Black Tusk commander
in New York stationed on Coney Island
he offered vitelli as a trade
knowing Kina and his past the commander
was suspicious and questioned kina's
motives
he simply stated that he has something
in mind for a future date
this only pushed her suspicions further
but the Russian scientist was too
valuable to pass up this offer
I expect him to have a virus he's clean
but if you're worried about it just put
him in quarantine
you really ain't making it easier to
trust you I'm sure you've got resources
at your disposal
stick him in a box and have your Medics
give them once over you'll see
he's healthy as anyone can be in this
situation yeah that's what I'm worried
about
worried that Vitalia might be infected
with the green poison he was placed in a
containment chamber so he could be
monitored before moving him on
Vivian Conley rogue agent in the newly
appointed leader of the cleaners is
approached by Aaron Keena he informs her
of the Telly's whereabouts and that the
lmb has hit him this whole time
without their leader they joined up with
the Black Tusk and were absorbed into
their ranks on top of this they handed
over custody of the Russian scientist
consumed by rage and thrilled with the
idea of being able to exec revenge on
someone they deemed responsible for
helping cause the dollar flew outbreak
Conley ordered the cleaners to assault
the Black Tusk on Coney Island
we're set
1600. meet at the ferry terminal [__]
yeah I can't believe you found that
[__] good to have friends on the
inside we ever gonna meet this Insider
cut the shatter sorry man all right
who's ready to collect your nanko's
ashes
the cleaners didn't know that Conley was
getting this information from Kina
firstly as Conley said they don't trust
Outsiders and secondly if we remember
from the West Side piers in the division
one all of the factions were hunting
Kina down so it's horrendously unlikely
that they would trust any intel coming
from him
and they would be right we can see from
these interactions that Kina isn't just
betraying the Black Tusk by sitting in
the cleaners to have their Revenge but
he's also manipulating a fellow rogue
agent in order to have her carry out his
plans
the tele training code doesn't know it
but he's the most valuable asset on the
planet right now
the shd Needham to oversee the
management and production of the
antivirals that are to be dispersed
among the population
the Black Tusk won and presumably for
the same reason when they managed to
recapture the bioreactor and antivirals
from the White House
and the cleaners well they just want to
see him burn
however unfortunately for the cleaners
the division beat them to it
they launch a strike on the island
having to throw all caution to the wind
in order to extract the telly
they had to strike hard and fast before
the Black Tusk had time to react
division managed to extract vitelli
before the unexpected attack from the
cleaners swept across the island
the division agents fall back as the
cleaners quickly begin to burn through
the remaining forces of Black Tusk
the Black Tusk Commander quickly catches
on that they have been betrayed by Kina
the shd find out the Keener is still
close and proceed to search for him on
the island
while the cleaners are burning
everything in sight and the bulk of the
Black Tusk Force has been kept busy the
division agents managed to come across
and kill the Black Tusk Commander
effectively putting an end to the Black
Tusk presence on Coney Island
control of the Drone
who the hell is doing this
[Music]
congratulations agent
you've got Sri Lanka
oh that's okay you can keep him
he has served his purpose
now this operation went much smoother
than I expected and that is partially
thanks to you
I know it's frustrating I'm right here
and you're right there
but never forget
I will always be one step ahead of you
I'm in control
because I'm not afraid to take control
you still follow orders
that's why you never win
I'll see you real soon
while scouting the island for the Drone
to locate Kina control of the Drone was
suddenly lost
although it seems that he wasn't
expecting the division to be involved in
this conflict he certainly doesn't
appear to be phased by their involvement
the division have once again missed
their opportunity to capture Kina
Aaron Kina now has his new virus his
next step was to build a cell of Rogue
agents to help carry out his plan
firstly Vivian Conley with the offer of
the tele traininko and Coney Island she
and her cleaners were already well under
the thumb of Kina
next was James dragoff it would be
brought on board along with his new
family the Rikers dragoff was completely
uninterested in joining his course
however he quickly changed his mind when
Kina started executing Rikers and
threatening to continue to take them
down until dragoff complied
Kina needed access to the supplies that
dragoff was able to acquire and the
ability to move them around the city
undetected
following this Keener approached Theo
Parnell a master hacker and a tech
genius he provided evidence backing up
parnell's growing suspicions about his
father's death conveying to him that the
people higher up had shown not to have
the best intentions of the people at
heart and that the division was corrupt
with this information he was able to
persuade him to join his side
and finally there was heavier kijika
Tina persuaded kajika to join him in
order for the names of the people that
betrayed khajika in his Squad during a
previous mission
so we now hit his team their first job
was to launch a collection of biological
attacks on sites around New York City
and these included City Hall a number of
highly populated areas and an assortment
of jtf facilities
it was this Catalyst that led the acting
commander of the division in New York
Bay Lao to request urgent help from the
agents in Washington DC
through the use of surveillance footage
the Washington agents quickly
established the Rogue operatives were a
group of former first wave agents being
led by Aaron Keena and this Revelation
is what triggered a city-wide Manhunt
for the infamous rogue agent
and deterred by the division's search
for him Kina continued with his
preparations with parnell's
technological expertise and dragoff's
uncanny ability to provide him with a
number of high-tech materials keena's
plan started to become a reality
the rogue agent network was built along
with more lethal forms of shd tech and
ground-to-air missiles that would
aspirating the virus
sir I've made some progress on the
network I'm listening I've got it
running in a test environment right now
it's virtually untraceable since we're
piggybacking off of Isaac's system he
can detect the signal but it's encrypted
until we don't want it to be what
features are we talking here it's full
Suite all the benefits without any
drawbacks and scalability in theory it's
unlimited I'm running some simulations
and it's already well beyond our current
needs and we can push out the update
from a single device that's genius Theo
I don't know about all that don't fail
yourself so short you've built an
amazing tool for us with incredibly
limited resources if you like that you
should see what else I got cooking up I
wish I had the time but you keep working
I look forward to seeing how this
progresses thank you sir
with his plans known full swing Kina had
very little need for his team of Rogue
agents anymore and allowed them to be
taken down one by one by the division
they had served their purpose
as a result of the Intel gathered from
the Rogue Watchers feylau was able to
pinpoint kina's location on Liberty
Island
the division agents quickly boarded a
fury and proceeded to kina's location
but the Black Tusk were also looking for
Kina and on their way to the island
launched a missile attack aimed at the
boat and was successful in destroying it
however the agent survived
the Black Tusk then sent Ground Forces
to stop Kina including a Razorback
missile launcher but the division
division quickly able to overwhelm their
forces
throwing in everything they had left the
black task sent a marauder-class
quadcopter and a number of warhounds
akina's new more advanced shd Tech was
able to hack the quadcopter and War
hounds and he turned them against the
division agents
the agents were successful in stopping
the Hacked forces but now that all black
task forces on the island had been
eliminated they had no choice but to
abandon the attack leaving Kina and the
division agents to finish the fight
fighting through kina's heavy spam of
shd tick the agents eventually cornered
him on the outside of the island where
he was preparing to launch his missiles
containing the new virus
but with only seconds to spear the
agents were able to destroy the missile
launcher
Kina then launched a head-on attack
using his Superior shd tick to push the
agents back
however during the attack he was heavily
wounded he managed to escape to the pier
but his injuries proved too much the
division agents caught up to him and
before they could stop him he activated
his rogue agent Network telling the
agents that they have no idea what is
coming before dying shortly after
at this stage the rogue agent Network
appears to be basically kina's version
of the shd essentially it looks like all
agents who have had the connection to
Isaac severed after going rogue now have
access to this new network with a new AI
called Anna
you Rogue agents we've come across so
far are from the first wave of division
agents released into New York in
Washington DC so it is possible that
these all the agents Kino was able to be
in contact with and possibly the reason
why Kino traveled to Washington DC after
we lost track of him in New York he was
recruiting but there are a number of
different types of Rogue agents out
there and not all of them would want to
be involved and some of them have even
been working with the Black Tusk and
want to get rid of the Rogue agents just
as badly as the division does
however it must be noted how far Aaron
keener's personality shifted from the
point to being left alone in the dark
Zone to the end of Warlords of New York
the jcf has pulled out and are preparing
a retreat from Manhattan the agents are
still alive
know that we are on our own
that's fine we don't need the jtf we
don't even need the division or the
government's permission to do what has
to be done we were trained for this to
complete the Mission Against All Odds to
ensure the continuity of government to
save what remains but what kind of
mission is that the government doesn't
care about us we're Expendable sure but
they have carelessly thrown us aside for
no reason and why should we sacrifice
ourselves for a state that doesn't
deserve it we still take a moment to
reflect on that and ask if the mission
still stands
me
I'm not so sure anymore
at the beginning around the outbreak
Keanu is highly intelligent and
Incredibly sure of himself he also
showed strong determination and
perseverance
after turning Rogue his Outlook changed
as he believed that the rules and laws
that used to govern them no longer exist
and that the only way to survive is by
being the one in control so as a
consequence of this he began to use his
abilities and manipulation and influence
to push others into achieving his goals
audio logs in Washington DC showed that
he started to develop a massive ego and
later on in lower Manhattan a huge
superiority complex was beginning to
emerge with an even greater thirst for
power
right up into the point of Warlords of
New York Kino was always two steps ahead
of the division yet his final encounter
played out like your typical action
movie with the crazy villain being
thwarted in his plans by the unflinching
hero and he was taken down fairly easily
the whole final mission plays out like
we caught him off guard except we didn't
he knew the division was coming and he
had plenty of opportunity to escape
remember he has never had any problems
with reminding the division that he he's
the smartest person in the room
yet to be caught out on an island with
no backup plan other than to take on the
division face to face doesn't quite fit
in with what we've seen from him up
until now
yes there is his legacy as he liked to
call it but did he really need to die in
order to unleash them
it's probably fair to say that Keener
certainly looked rather weathered for
the time we got to him perhaps his life
on the Run had finally got the best of
him and he had nothing more to give I
mean they do say that there is a very
fine line between genius and Insanity
perhaps he fell over that line long
before we caught up with him
is trying to save the City by trying to
blow up the city because he feels that's
how to save the city because he feels
betrayed by the government
it's clear that Kina was done with
Society he had lost faith in mankind
he seemed to believe that it was his
responsibility to help reset society and
hypothesize that by killing the vast
amount of the population with the virus
only a select few would survive due to
their natural immunity and or their
ability to adapt to this new environment
as a consequence of this a new society
would be born
this all sounds very similar to what the
creator of the dollar flu had in mind Dr
Gordon Amherst but even then what does
the rogue agent Network have to do with
any of this why were they only activated
at that moment as he was dying and what
is their overall goal
again it isn't very keenourish just to
activate them with the sole purpose of
being a general nuisance this surely
must be more to it
or maybe I'm looking at this from the
wrong direction let's go back to the
black task and Natalia Circle over for a
second
this organization or their employees at
least represents everything that Kenneth
stands against and with President Alice
at this time being on their payroll and
no government to remove his presidency
he was still technically the president
so there is the potential there that
Ellis or anyone who could control Isaac
may have been capable of marking all
remaining agents as Rogue
or alternatively he could have declared
the shd deactivated and Mark all of
those who refused to conform as Rogues
and if any of this did happen the
division would be severely crippled when
they lose access to Isaac and the
network
however because of kina's rogue agent
Network they'll be able to continue on
as normal with potentially even more
capability
but this didn't happen
division agents were able to proceed as
normal
perhaps the activation of the road
network was only in the situation that
he failed
or maybe he realized that he would need
to die in order for the division to
redirect their focus on the true
objective
up until this point the division had
been investing a lot of their time and
resources into finding Kina
and maybe in order for them to finally
see the big picture he needed to
eliminate himself from the scenario
with Kina gone the true enemy would be
revealed
he had always been fighting against the
government and any other organization
that mimics government for example the
Black Tusk
sure what is left of the division is a
nuisance to Kina but they have never
been his main priority
in his eyes they just hadn't seen the
light yet
maybe he knew that he would eventually
have to make the ultimate sacrifice for
the people to help the division on the
right path
notice I didn't say killing people is
easy if you think of them as people it
suddenly gets that much harder
but if you simply look at the balance
sheet how much of an obstacle someone is
or how much benefit there is in letting
them keep breathing a while longer
then it becomes simple math
and simple math is simple to do
it's almost as easy as putting two
bullets Center Mass and a third one in
the head
so I guess the question lies was the
rogue agent Network kina's last gift to
the division
in year 5 season 3 I'm hoping we see a
number of answers to the questions we've
had since his death
some of the big ones for me include why
have we heard nothing about the rogue
agent Network or Anna since his death
was what he called his legacy more than
just a cell of Rogue agents
and why did Kino go all weird and out of
character at the end there also while
I'm in it I'm sorry stovepipe I know
everyone keeps calling you the pretty
one but Keener is the ultimate Bachelor
of this franchise not you
maybe I'll either type anyway thank you
very much for watching I actually really
enjoyed catching up on kina's Intel in
this video and sadly it's actually
reigned my anger towards the writers for
killing him off but you know hopefully
this upcoming season will help me get
over this thanks again and extremist
mullus extreme remedia
you might be wondering why I'm leaving
these
perhaps it's a deep-seated need for
confession and then again maybe not I
haven't done anything I'm not proud of
and I have no need to seek Absolution
from anyone least from all you
maybe I'm bored
it's hard being one step ahead of
everyone else and this is my way of
giving you a little bit of a helping
hand to make things more challenging
of course that's the sort of thing made
up villains do
nah I'm perfectly happy to maximize my
advantage
or maybe I just want to get you spinning
in circles
now check for yourself are there subtle
contradictions in what I told you is it
hard to figure out what I'm trying to
tell you
maybe that's the point
then again
maybe it isn't
[Music]
[Applause]